thank you very much glad to be here
thank you for coming
before I begin today in the interest of
full disclosure I am a lawyer I have and
I have practiced in the area of as a pro
bono lawyer in children's rights with
regard to disabilities and special
education for about 23 years in addition
I'm a customer 11 years ago I had was
fortunate enough to give birth to a
child who has autism and is a delightful
young man who has benefited greatly from
the services of many of the folks in
this room and Yale Child Study Center so
I appreciate that and their made me a
mix of law and life because I've had to
do it from both sides it's a lot easier
to represent someone else's child I can
surely tell you that okay so today we're
going to talk a little bit about the
legal rights of children with autism and
related disorders in reality until very
recently that's all been sort of folded
into the legal rights of children with
disabilities autism didn't get a lot of
special attention until fairly recently
and so much of the law that applies to
children special education needs it's
very broad but it applies to children
with autism so I'll talk a little bit
about that but because of my perspective
on it I wanted to start with the
chronological look from the parent the
eyes of the parent who's told their
child has has autism because that's kind
of a stunning revelation and for many
their first thought about law you know
you come in and your child is diagnosed
and that has it's obvious ramifications
in terms of how you feel socially and
personally emotionally it's the clinical
response I haven't got doctors I've got
to become involved with all sorts of
specialists I don't even know what ot
means and now I need one and then
there's also the emotional response of
will I go to the wedding will there be
soccer and crazy kinds of things run
through your mind so you know that ran
through my mind even though I was a
disability
first thought was not at all about what
I was going to do legally for my child
the real scary part is when you walk out
the door of any doctor's office any
facility after being told that your
child has autism
because there's no plan you kind of are
used in life to walking out with the
list and here's you do this if you do
this then this will happen and then this
and logical progression and you know at
least in my experience that's not what
happens you get a diagnosis you might
get some websites you get some referrals
it takes a long time sometimes to get
appointments with the next set of
individuals and so you are really left
with this interval where you end up with
lots of information you begin to worried
you know I need to go to law school
because right away people will tell you
horror stories about special education
and quackery and cures and you begin to
really worry about legal rights first
thing you think is I cannot die so you
worry about you know setting up a trust
a special needs trust for your child so
all kinds of legal things that you
weren't thinking about with this darling
little you know - my two year old
suddenly jumped to the forefront you
want to figure out how do you navigate
the rest of your life and this really
becomes a legal issue not just one that
is in terms of the child but you're the
manager of your child's case essentially
as a parent and I think that's important
to know as a disability lawyer I was as
dumbfounded as anyone who has ever
gotten an autism diagnosis and was
completely incapable for a very long
time of really addressing that in an
unemotional way what you really have to
worry about is people talk about best
interest of the child always in the law
but what you're really thinking about
now is it's not the best interest of the
child it's this child and what is
legally possible to do and ethically
possible and educationally and socially
possible lots of things run through your
mind so parents are confused what is a
family to do you have this lovely
odd little creature who you adore and
you know you need to take care of for
the rest of your life and how are you
going to set things up so that other
people want to care for your child will
meet their social and legal obligations
and he or she will be educated in the
best possible fashion so that's sort of
the background that most parents walk
into the legal windmill not just the
medical one that's when the real
struggles begin is to get a little bit
of knowledge and then it becomes quite
overwhelming there's this new language
and the the acronym world
I had thought I'd known it all but not
yet new jargon latest studies all sorts
of things I'm going to talk a little bit
about jargon today and some of the great
famous acronyms acronyms rather may be
Akron isms that people need to know when
they begin to deal with a child with
autism would not have been in the normal
person's lexicon prior to that you know
the only one who might not be talking to
you is the child his or him or herself
and and that's the devastating part
really you're being spoken to and at and
around if you're not there about legal
issues and what are you going to do and
you've got in many instances this little
silent person it's really the focus of
all of this so you're very concerned
about protecting that person's rights
parents find themselves thrust into an
educational system that is sooner than
they planned and they may have just been
planning on the school bus and crayons
and off we go to regular old school and
now it's thoughts of the dreaded short
bus and how do I get that and when does
it begin and how do I get my child into
the system it's really not a
well-formulated process for that to
occur so that's a great concern to
parents we get too much advice we get
bad advice we get some good advice but
we get plenty of advice
all of it from the sources we would like
and not at the times we want some of it
from charlatans some of it from people
who would prefer to just have us beat
this demon out of our child some in
grocery stores and some violate via
email circuit solicitations we also get
to little advice you know what you
really want to know is what are the top
five things I need to do right now to
formulate this worth my quarterback call
in the play and I will do this so it's
this odd dilemma we find ourselves in we
know there's law out there how do you
tap into it how do you begin to initiate
this and in a way that's hopefully going
to be the appropriate balance for your
child because you're in a negotiation
this is maybe the first mediation
parents have ever had to engage in and
it's very very high stakes you know with
autism the earlier you start getting an
appropriate program in place the better
and that pressure is coming at a time
when you may or may not be among the
most devastated and debilitated and
sleepy that you've ever been so legal
distinctions become all of a sudden very
important labels become important
parents may resist the idea of a child
getting an autism label in my mind that
label becomes a very important box to
check later on and I want the label had
to be talked into the label myself as I
recall that it's an important box to
check in terms of getting services so
there's these emotional hurdles I don't
want to label my child and and yet we
realize it becomes necessary thing I
think it's interesting about autism to
me is it's sort of the intersection of
medicine and law because you have a
disease and I saw it personally I
sometimes call it you know educating the
plague we've got this thing that just
seems to be expanding it's everywhere we
all know people with this but it doesn't
get cured you don't go in and get
surgery or a pill if you see improvement
it's this arduous process and you've got
to be very much engaged in it and it has
to be treated at every stage of your
life you realize that you're going to
have to envy
the law and precedent and some types of
maybe legal services or legal knowledge
to be able to help cure or treat your
child you know some of the things that
deal with that autism obviously you know
can be handled medically those tend to
be more sort of side-effects and kind of
peripheral things that don't go
necessarily to the heart of autism and
the behavior and so that intervention
happens in a weird place that schools
become your hospital and very often
certainly in the olden days of you know
10 years ago the hospital wasn't ready
to receive this patient in many places
they still are not and so a parent may
have the role of becoming educator of
legal obligations and educational
obligations to people who either don't
know or don't want to know or seem to
have forgotten what the law is regarding
special education for children on the
spectrum in my personal opinion this is
somewhat heresy to say as an attorney
but if there if you were ever going to
have autism there's never been a better
time in the history of the United States
to have it I don't want it would prefer
it didn't exist but we are light years
ahead of where we would have been a
number of years ago certainly in my own
case my child would be feral and
nonverbal had we not had laws that
helped us get appropriate intervention
and medical treatment at appropriate
stages so while I'm the first one to
complain I will say that the laws have
actually have helped they've brought us
forward leaps and bounds boy we need
advocates you know every parent every
person who deals with children with
autism it's my expectation that they
should be engaged in some form of
appropriate advocacy and that requires
you know some some effort and some
education so it's not over but I will
say it's better than it used to be and I
think it's getting more enlightened via
the world is getting more enlightened
every day in the United States I can
talk a little bit later about what might
be happening globally to some extent I'm
not gonna go through this exhaustively
but this we didn't get to where we are
today on the backs of nothing a whole
lot of things happen to me the most
important thing that happened was
something that seems unrelated unrelated
at all is Brown versus Board of
Education we all know that as you know
bless Thurgood Marshall for coming up
with the the case and arguing it
successfully this is the Supreme Court
and it was a civil rights case involving
racial segregation in schools but what
brown did was stick the toe in the door
of saying oh yeah wait separate but
equal disparate treatment you know
children need an education and people
began to then think oh yeah what about
disabled children what about gender what
about issues of age and fairness and so
brown to me is truly in the United
States the springboard to a whole array
of later acts of Congress and litigation
and it kind of opened the doors I'm
going to go through this very quickly
but just to show you sort of pile on
what happened we then move into an
elementary and secondary school
Education Act then the education of the
handicapped act immune system of the
archaic terminology we are still dealing
with terms in some of this law of these
laws and the legislative history is
about feeble mindedness and you know
some of this occurred in the era of the
theory of the refrigerator mom for
autism and something said that's even
still out there in some corners and it's
astounding
who's going to enact legislation to help
a child with autism when the mother
caused it you know maybe she should be
prosecuted but maybe she should court
cure this - so a whole host of laws and
cases came up setting precedents such as
that the state or the city or the school
board has an obligation to help pay for
the education of children
special needs or that they should be
brought into the public school system
they can't be denied a public education
important things like section 504 of the
Rehabilitation Act which I'll go into
later help to establish very basic
rights we have the education for all
handicapped children Act again we're
referring specifically to children and
having a handicap autism at this time
was still in a state of sort of early
acceptance and it was you know even to
this day people said aren't you
fortunate your charles's are artistic
and so you have to try to really work to
educate people Congress needed it to the
let you know it everyone needed it and
so appropriate lobbying was done by
doctors and advocacy groups so we go
through this whole host of gradual
piling on of Acts amendments and each
one of them is a slight expansion over
the other one of various rights and
responsibilities of government and
educational agencies Americans
discipline Disabilities Act is very well
known it's having its 20th the birthday
this year I mean it seems incredible
that twenty years ago we didn't have the
ABA and you know we had the famous case
of the mayor in a city and Connecticut
saying I'm not building the damn ramp
I'll just carry that little crippled
child up the stairs it'll she want to
see you as the library so it really took
things like the ad a to add some
robustness to making public places of
public accommodation more accessible and
available to people certainly an
important individuals with Disabilities
Education Act IDE a or idea has been
very important and probably the most
important
act from the from my perspective in the
area of special education with
amendments we have the interesting No
Child Left Behind litigation or a
legislation rather of 2001 and then we
have the individuals with Disabilities
Education Improvement Act of 2004 which
sort of wrote on the coattails of No
Child Left Behind and added some new
layers and dimensions to the I DEA we
also have pending state and federal like
legislation and I'm not going to talk
about States now because it will just
take too long no that it's better to be
a person with autism in some states
versus others
even though we have federal law the
delivery of services is so widely varied
just within our own state from one city
or town to another but certainly in
entire states you see a great disparity
so most of the litigation involves areas
where people have fallen through the
cracks you know a right seems to be
federally mandated and not delivered
upon so that's sort of the background in
the context for why people take a look
at federal legislation to me the most
important are the I DEA you know has
improved in 2004 or the new idea we
can't stop calling it by the old acronym
it's too hard to come up with a new one
we have the Americans with Disabilities
Act and the Rehabilitation Act of 1973
also sometimes shorthand it is section
504 okay but you know the one that I
think is most practical for daily life
for many of our children on the spectrum
is the I DEA and one of the things the
IEA does is requires that each children
should have an individualized
educational program and that that
child's education should be tailored to
that person's specific needs so you
can't go in up we've got
autism pick our garden our
garden-variety autism program off the
educational shelf locked the child up in
a room with all the other autistic
children and put in the tape certainly
has happened and is the urge in many
areas educating children with autism is
an extremely expensive proposition and
that's why you know it's in some ways
unfair that the schools have to educate
a disability a medical condition but
that's where it happens that's that's
where the best chances are and so things
like the ID EA have recognized that
you've got to put into place a very
specific program now in order to
determine what is specifically an
educationally appropriate for a child
you have to evaluate that child
individually and presumably impartial E
and there are rights that flow from that
school district may require that a child
be evaluated parents may also require
that you may also bring in outside
evaluations to be used as persuasive
authority to help determine what is an
educationally appropriate program we
have to have input from a team there has
to be information from educators
specialists and it should be parental or
guardian participation which is a whole
new thing of it used to be people would
go into the room and come out and tell
you here's what's going to happen with
the rest of your child's life and the
legislation and litigation caused a very
significant change in allowing and in
fact mandating parental or guardian
participation in this process it's very
important somebody's got to go home with
the child at the end of the day and
should not only be knowledgeable about
what the goals and the aspects of the
educational program are about what they
can do themselves and it's been a source
of a lot of litigation which has helped
to define the contours of what is
available when one meets with an
individual for an individualized
educational program
goes by a lot of different names there's
team meetings in Connecticut it's
typically called a PPT meeting but the
goal is to come up with this
individualized educational program and
come up with a document the goal is
actually consensus this is not easily
achieved and sometimes consensus is only
folk and census whereas you may have a
roomful of special educators and school
officials and social workers and then
there's a parent sitting alone on the
other side of the table this is very
daunting the law to some extent tries to
offer the parent and ability to to
comment and participate and sign off on
these things but you know in reality
your typical parent finds this
overwhelming and it's emotionally a very
hard experience I was unable to
represent my own child at IEP s4 in the
IEP process for the first two years
after his diagnosis and I had been doing
it for other people's children for
probably 1012 years at that point so
case in point it's just very difficult
and it may be that sometimes educational
programs the the deck is stacked a bit
in their favor and you may be given a
program for your child it looks a lot
like the last child who came in and it
may not be quite as individualized and
so that's what parents often talk and
gripe about and worry about is that it's
not truly individualized but it may fit
an economic or educational program that
already is suitable for that school
district so those are some of the issues
now the four basic tenants of the ID EA
are to provide free and appropriate
public education for children with
disabilities and autism is specifically
one of the enumerated disabilities which
is why you want that box checked on the
forms and it should emphasize special
education and the child's unique needs
it also protects the rights of children
with disabilities and parental rights
and having the parent as part of the
process is essential parent or guardian
and getting them involved early and
often is a good thing it's a very
fatiguing condition parents are often
burned-out emotional not necessarily
always on their best game and so this
can be an overwhelming process ID is
also meant to assist the states and
local schools in the provision of
special education and assess and assure
the effectiveness of special education
these are sort of the lofty aspirational
goals of the idea it was reauthorized in
2004 and there's been a number of
iterations so you should know that when
you speak of these things as in most
things there's a layer of overlapping
laws we have all of the ones I show it
in the long laundry list also our you
know many are still in place some of the
laws are still good precedent or there
are later cases that come in that help
modify it but it's really a lot of
layers to this this special ed onion so
but the fact that autism is specifically
cited as a covered disability is very
relevant for parents when the Act was
made a bit more robust and was tweaked
in 2004 and a little bit beyond it's
increased the focus on the
accountability of schools and
successfully educating children with
disabilities this ties and I'll talk a
little bit later about No Child Left
Behind but there's an increased emphasis
on outcome measures and which strategies
actually work
emphasis on measurable goals and outcome
metrics so assessments are done
standardized testing has become part of
the routine there are requirements as
special education teachers get this B
spec be specialists in special education
and be highly qualified
not always the case sometimes you
wondered if someone had been taken out
of the kitchen in a hairnet and you know
toss into a special ed classroom just to
sort of hold the peace and that changed
so that's a wonderful requirement and
not only the teachers but also
paraprofessionals and other people who
work with our students with autism and
related disorders so there are
requirements that they not only be
highly qualified and receive some
education now this may not always happen
but it offers parents and others an
opportunity to explore that more fully
with the school system if it doesn't but
also the instructional strategy should
be grounded in scientifically based
research to be honest when I first began
to do this some of the theories and the
rationale for the proposed IEP or
program that was being put forth for the
child
sounded like witchcraft it's I have
heard it said well yes there is a son
called applied behavior analysis ABA but
that's only for children who bark like
seals and are you know terribly terribly
disabled and you wouldn't want to limit
your child to that kind of a lifestyle
you wouldn't want to do that to your
child and so we have this great you know
mainstream classroom and you really
don't need that service but service is
expensive and time-consuming and very
difficult to find people who are
qualified practitioners in it I
understand that but if that's what's in
order it should be provided and so
parents are not supposed to be talked
out of the appropriate therapies
undereye da states actually have to ne
enact child fine procedures so they need
to go look for these kids and there's an
intranet interesting act that is a
subset of the IEA requiring that for
example homeless children be sought out
in shelters and in other places migrants
and be evaluated if need be to look for
developmental disabilities or the hints
of developmental disabilities and if so
brought into the system and received
evaluations same things for children in
private schools I should say that what
forced me into the system was there was
an insert in my paycheck one week that
said do you think your child may have a
delay or a disability I've been in
denial up until that point but it was
actually an outreach that was mandated
by the state and I read that there was a
toll-free number and it was sort of a
whistleblower line because it said if
you're the grandparent friend neighbor
anything to anybody who you think might
have this call this number and we'll get
somebody out there and it was at that
point that I realized that it's time to
get the head out of the sand and do
something they're really making outreach
efforts so evaluation should occur and
of course this is very difficult with
some populations if you've got migrant
workers you have people with significant
language or educational backgrounds that
just they don't understand what autism
is cultural clashes occur and so it's a
very delicate balance at some point of
trying to bring children into the system
also of children being brought in and
maybe resisted you don't want to label
your child we would like to put this off
so the law wants these children to be
brought in and evaluated to see if they
do have a developmental disability and
if so what that might be and how it
could be addressed the goal is early
intervention if a child is determined to
have
or a covered disability there's a
requirement that they receive a free
appropriate public education and Stape
or whatever you want to call it this is
supposed to be a specially designed
instructional program at no cost to the
parents or the Guardian and this concept
is terrific in in actually implementing
it it can be very rough school systems
are sometimes under-equipped
in some areas of the country is very
difficult to find appropriate
specialists there may not be a large
population of children with not just
autism but whatever disability should
present itself and so it's difficult but
a program that deals with this
individualized child this individual
child should be creative it should
include all education related services
such as transportation developmental
assistance and support services not
necessarily part of the regular
curriculum so that could be things like
speech and again think of yourself as a
parent who has no clue what any of this
is ot PT the alphabet soup comes out and
we really don't know what these are
someone says do you want ot you may
think don't know what that is I don't
want to sound stupid I'll just decline
and if no one is there to explain this
to a parent or they haven't done a lot
of homework services that can be very
very important may in fact not end up as
part of this child's training curriculum
I should also point out that when they
say a free appropriate public education
doesn't mean you get the Cadillac the
rolls-royce of public education here and
there's been a lot of legislation and
litigation about this I think the Rowley
case is one of them
it means appropriate doesn't mean the
best or the one that's guaranteed to get
the best possible outcome of all others
for your individual child
it means outcome that's legally
comparable to the quality of education
given to a typical student so while it's
supposed to be
individualized it is not going to be one
that is meant to make your child
superior to all others and receive
something that a typical child would not
normally receive or a similarly situated
child with your disabilities such as
autism that's a very fine line to dance
and that's an area where there's a lot
of litigation and foment some discontent
and unrest among parents and advocates
for children with disabilities because
what is appropriate you know if you are
a parent appropriate is the best you can
possibly do for your child if you're a
school system it's what do I have here
that will fill that need and not err on
the side of excessive services when the
team meets the team is legally required
to produce an IEP document so that's an
individualized educational program for
your child and that's supposed to be a
collaborative process attended many of
these meetings where these are being
drafted and collaboration isn't
necessarily always the word that comes
to mind but in in the perfect world it
is supposed to be collaborative and
parents are supposed to have input one
thing parents and others who are
advocating on behalf of children might
realize is that they have the right to
be able to request some of the
documentation in advance so there's a
lot of testing of your child of a child
list with autism and special needs
before you go to these meetings from the
parental perspective legal perspective
it is good to not walk in blind in a
courtroom we would never walk in without
delivery of discovery documents
beforehand to know what we were dealing
with it appears to be more often than
not that families or a single parent is
often the case show up at a PPT with no
knowledge about what's going to be
presented and so one thing I would
suggest that if it's really
collaborative the people representing
the child the parent or the Guardian
would have access to the same
information testing
most recent scores data etc that
everybody else in the room does before
you go in and that that I would say in
of all the PPT meetings and IEP planning
meetings I've been to has been the
single biggest failing is to provide
that information in advance so that
others have a chance to absorb it
maybe question it rather than receive it
as a fait accompli this is your child
take them or leave them this is what we
think and we're the experts and so an
IEP has to be in place at the beginning
of the school year for every child with
a disability or as soon thereafter as is
practical so when a child comes into the
system one of the first things you do is
begin to plan the IEP meeting typically
they're held at the end of one school
year to plan for the next year's meaning
you're trying to set very measurable
goals and and IEP is kind of a a
daunting thing I happen to have one with
me I just want to point out that this is
the document that's supposed to be
produced in the 45 minutes or so that is
allowed for you to discuss your child's
entire next year which is often how
frequently pts or IEP planning meetings
happen and it's small type has a lot of
goals lots of columns everyone else in
the room understands the jargon in the
language and even at this state I find
myself with you know very strong glasses
fumbling wildly and having them mark
it's very difficult to read educators
knows that we're familiar with the IEP
process are fluent in this your typical
parent guardian advocate is is not as
long with it
sometimes they are prepared before you
even would walk into the door so it's
sort of like getting going in and
negotiate a pre written contract so and
it sets forth this is the contract what
this says is what your child is going to
get or not
unless you're in a situation where you
have a school system where they are more
flexible and will say you know gee we
think we see something coming up not
reflected in the IEP we have the right
to then say let's convene another IEP
meeting and draft a new document or make
a change and remenham in turn or
revision and it could sometimes even be
done just without just with parental or
guardian consent but this says what your
child's going to be doing for the next
presumably year and it sets forth very
measurable goals in many areas in with
regards to testing teaching language
speech every single area of development
so the reality of this is producing
something satisfying and holistic and
appropriate in the typical 45-minute
meeting it's very slim so my suggestion
is to have the documentation in advance
to have reviewed it closely these forms
are available online and you can see
what you know you're going to be looking
at what benchmarks might be set for your
child you can request these and then
have your own set of goals in mind too
so the key to effective IEP meaning for
parent guardian from the parental
perspective at least is to go in
well-prepared and with a set of succinct
questions try to remain as unemotional
as humanly possible sometimes difficult
one catches more flies by being a
reasonable and rational person it's
better to to walk away and reconvene
than get into an altercation frankly in
my experience but it's a very highly
charged and emotional issue so I just
mentioned that sometimes things break
down and people either can't agree or
won't agree or you hit some impasse or
there's not strict implementation of
what has been agreed upon and parents
Guardians
and sometimes school districts do have
the right to bring things to a due
process hearing and that is a that's
what it sounds like it's it's a
administrative hearing where a skilled
trained hearing officer hopefully would
be reviewing the complaints and the
rebuttals from both sides and trying to
figure out where the problems lie is
there overreaching on the part of one
party under performance on the part of
another where is the IP IEP falling
short etc so there are mechanisms built
within the IDE a to allow in other laws
to allow for due process hearings and
then again people can always go to court
- there's quite a body of certainly
federal litigation in end state
regarding disability education one of
the things that's mandated in the IDE is
the least restrictive environment and
this is something that you know seems
like it makes sense now but for people
who have been around for more than
twenty years
we remember the days of the training
schools and the special school and where
a child might have been taken away and
put in a very restrictive environment
because unmanageable refrigerator mother
has caused the situation I have no doubt
that forty years ago my child would be
nonverbal probably in a training school
being visited on Saturdays if we still
remembered him and would be
you know not the speaking happy playing
going to camp kid that we have so
talking about least restrictive
environment I can't emphasize the puffs
it requires that children with
disabilities should be educated in the
least restrictive environment to meet
their individual needs and goals doesn't
mean childless we fully mainstreamed and
mainstreaming is is the goal but it can
be done with variations and permutations
of that so there may be pull outs from a
regular classroom for speech and ot
there are some cases that hold that
there's certain cases and children and
types of disabilities where that's not
possible so some some laws have held
that or some cases have held that you
can't have special autism unit within a
school but what we don't want is the old
days of segregation
remember this started with brown v board
of education and so the idea of pulling
our child children away and putting them
in segregated area for a very special
and different type of education is not
the goal we want them to be inclusive as
I said there have been cases that have
held the placement in special and
separate autism you know within a school
can meet the least restrictive
restrictive environment and not deprive
a student of faith however even then
there would be times when the children
should be brought together and that's in
most of the cases things like lunch
things you know common areas that all
children do still meant to be brought
together when possible and when not a
danger to themselves or others that dad
of course standard various we don't want
children who are engaging in self
injurious behavior or hurting others and
yet modeling with typical peers may in
fact be the best way to help reduce that
kind of behavior so it's a fine line
when it gets fought out fairly
frequently and I know that one quite
well myself many parents have a
knee-jerk reaction and say I have to
find the best private school for my
child this public school is not going to
work well no the public school is not
required to pay for private education
unless they can't do it you know if they
can't effectively educate your child
then private education may in fact be an
order and you may be entitled to it in
money or in most cases it takes going to
a due process hearing to be able to
establish that burden of proof that
there's been a failure on the part of
the school system I met with the parent
last week who said I don't want to send
my child in and have them fail free year
and regress and feel just awful about
themselves before they can go to the
place that we know they need to go
unfortunately or realistically the law
says the schools are supposed to be
making a good-faith effort to do this
and many in most cases they are if it
doesn't work then you move to that step
and there are a number of special
schools for children with autism and
developmental disorders and lots of
other disabilities but that's thought to
be there is the last resort so that's a
place where you go because it isn't the
least restrictive environment it is in
fact segregating your child to a large
extent with children with a similar
disability and not mainstreaming them so
and they're very expensive it expense
can't be forgotten as part of this so
take a child out of the school system
remember transportation is included in
this possibly an aide so there may be
not only you know the little van comes
in the morning and takes your child away
to a remote school but there will be an
aide on that bus to help your child the
private school tuition must be borne by
the school district there's a lot of
things and encompassed in this that
aren't very expensive and actually that
often acts as an incentive for schools
to broaden their range of services at
least that's what I found recently is
that schools are becoming more inclusive
and more interested in expanding
services
maybe partly because the economic
disincentive of placing kids out in in a
private setting one of the things that
exists is the early intervention
services and I think I mentioned my pay
stub that was when you know I had a 15
month old who began to speak in a German
accent one day and then stop the next
and I wasn't quite sure that was but
everybody said oh don't worry it's just
a phase the pay stub said if you think
your kid has a developmental disability
and seems to be doing something unusual
and it's not on track you can call your
mother can call your neighbor can call
and so federal grants arguments estates
for the impotent implementation of these
early intervention programs and what
they're trying to do is capture kids
early on and bring them into the system
some of these things maybe again just a
phase a quirk we want to make sure it
may be something more serious and that's
where some preliminary diagnosis and
treatment can be done the services
should be customized and they can be
formed and they should be formalized
with an individual Family Services plan
and it should be no cost to the family
in this state it's called birth to three
in there's a different name in almost
every state but it's meant to bring
young children into the system early
enough so that if it's something that
can be jump started with some quick
therapy fine if it's something that
points to a longer-term problem we begin
to document that and set that up so that
when the child becomes 3 they can enter
the regular school system
my child was 3 years and 4 hours before
he went into the regular school system
so it's it's fairly robust it was all
all ready to go and it does allow for
services that are related directly to
autism ABA speech language Cote PT the
whole array of acronyms
another thing children with autism are
entitled to and children with other
disabilities is
standard school year so the esy or se if
a student requires because that's the
typo in extended school year so that's
beyond the traditional number of days
which is typically around 180 185 or so
to accomplish the fait then you get the
extended school year or should get the
extended school year often it won't be
offered but it should be requested it's
no longer necessary to prove that a
child would significantly regress in
order to get an extended school year
although that is very often given as a
reason for denying an extended school
year but you do have to establish what
the level of impairment is the the
length of the gap some children may in
fact require extended school year just
through short holiday breaks really
depends and you know schools have
varying degrees of how much they're
willing to go along with but a lot of it
has to do with whether or not your child
is going to continue to progress stay
the same may regress or whether that
child is just dependent upon those daily
services and if an extended school year
is given it could include the whole
array of things that the child would get
during the school year or it could be
profoundly different it could be
something like going to camp with an
aide to have more additional
mainstreaming or it could be intensive
speech ot behavioral therapy whatever
ABA cetera okay so another Act the
Rehabilitation Act of 1973 is a little
I'm kind of going backwards a little bit
because with this is what we used before
we had a lot of other things in our
arsenal this is often called a section
504 or just 504 and it was really
legislation designed to end
discrimination against individuals with
disabilities and so it was an attempt to
improve services in education in a world
where there was very little service or
education specifically for people with
disabilities one of the more robust bits
of it was that it prohibits
discrimination not only by the US
government and
contractors and those receiving federal
funds but if you're getting federal
grants or a Druze aid you're covered
under section 504 well but for the
exception of a minuscule number of
schools and school systems and
educational institutions in the country
almost everybody gets some form of
federal aid and so therefore section 504
would apply to these places and it was
what we really hung our hat on before we
had a lot of other you know more evolved
litigation and robust legislation
Americans with Disabilities Act as I
said is only 20 years old and it was
based in a large part on section 504 of
the Rehabilitation Act it took it a step
further and it really addressed the
rights of individuals with disabilities
in many many areas of life in employment
in education in places of public
accommodation and other activities the
public accommodation portion of that's
important because public accommodation
is pretty much if there's a private
business someone wants to go to and
there's an impediment to getting into
there or for preventing their use of it
accommodation has to be made under
fairly broad guidelines so with the
beginning of the ad a1 began to see for
example ramps being built into
architecture so architectural barriers
had to come down you know and in the
early days of disability litigation
people would say things like well if
there's no legs fine I'll deal with that
you know we'll cover that but these
hidden disabilities I don't just tell
the child to fly straight and behave and
act right and so it took much longer for
the world to evolve from the actual
visual disability that could be easily
verified by any layperson - the ones
that much more subtle and nuanced in
fact many parents with children with
autism even if their child is perfectly
verbal will
sign because that sends a signal through
the world that I've got this special
child
stay away don't come up and tell me to
beat him he's acting out because he has
autism not because he's a bad child and
so it just is code for leave us alone
sad to still be using things like that
but I do it all the time
so the a da addressed both the public
and the private sector and so it really
extended the provisions of and
protections at 504 43 million Americans
with disabilities had very little
recourse against discrimination there
were some laws in the books you know 504
etcetera saying you can't do it but
there weren't a lot of teeth in it you
know there weren't a lot of damages that
weren't attorneys fees available so
there wasn't that much litigation the
ABA was much more robust much more
widely promoted and anticipated and
hailed and it prohibited discrimination
based on documented disability and so
there is a requirement that you have
certain types and natures of
disabilities and it requires reasonable
accommodations so not everything it has
to be something that is feasible in the
workplace and other settings and that's
pretty broad
it covers individuals with autism that's
what makes it important for this lecture
employers can't discriminate against
people with disabilities now you have to
be otherwise qualified under the ABA
so you know a person with a third grade
education couldn't say well you know I
really wanted to go to your medical
school and that's my goal
under the ad a you know you have to be
otherwise qualified so you have to have
met certain benchmarks but it certainly
does help a child who or an individual
who has a disability who does meet the
criteria from being overtly
discriminated again
public services such as transportation
and government and some entities may not
discriminate and must accommodate no one
ever heard of an yelling bus twenty
years ago I mean these are these are new
things public commendations owned by a
private entity can't discriminate or
have architectural barriers if you think
about just that alone the what that did
for the architecture and building
industry you see a lot of really ugly
ramps out there now that we're
retrofitted but it's important open
doors literally four doorways were
widened lots of things happened and
telecommunications have to be accessible
all segments of our population many many
of our children are not verbal and so it
allows for you know people to use
adaptive technology and brought that
much more into the prominence and in
schools and in the workplace so eighty
eight isn't really an Education Act in
terms of it is a special ed thing but it
does allow it does bring education
within it and it allows for men and
monetary damages so we do see more
litigation since the ABA has come into
place and there's certain parameters for
being covered by it by it and it also
allowed professionals with disabilities
to enter the workplace wonderful models
maybe for children who have the
disability themselves and others
well that's what I'm going to mention is
No Child Left Behind that was I think it
was 1980 or 81 no 90 or 91 but it
required all public schools to bring
every child up to state standards in
reading and math within specified time
frames based on testing it is varied
testing oriented it is daunting to the
parents of children with disabilities a
double-edged sword here the goal was to
improve the academic achievement of the
disadvantaged but it did not it counts
our children's accomplishments or lack
thereof on standardized testing in
whether or not a school
have failed so this is something that is
a great importance to schools many
schools teach to the annual test there's
a fear that children will with
disabilities might be segregated into an
already failing school because that can
be sacrificed and if our kids aren't
going to accomplish at the same rate as
other children they might just be put in
there and allowed fail so people have to
do this so vigilant about that okay so
there's other legislation the combating
approach autism Appropriations Act did
appropriate 184 million dollars as part
of the 2009 omnibus appropriations act
that is not much money really when you
think of a hundred and eighty four
million dollars for a country is not a
lot it was eight I like to think of it
as the first drop in that bucket it's
maybe the Brown versus Board of
Education beginning to open some doors
there's some pending things too and the
autism treatment acceleration Act of
2009 although were in 2010 now it
proposes comprehensive autism
legislation services for adults which is
an ever-growing issue I mean nobody ever
thinks about adults in these things but
what happens then another legal issue
you know we'll have to face is an
increasing number of people with autism
being arrested and becoming part of the
judicial system the you know the prison
population etc mandatory inclusion of
diagnosis and treatment for autism by
insurance insurance has been probably
the single largest impediment for
families trying to get services for
their children if they're not able to
get everything from a school they
couldn't also get it from on their own
there's also some other things pending
like the Ebel accounts Act of 2009 and
very simplistically that would maybe
allow people to put aside some money in
a tax protected area that wouldn't
automatically child prevent a child from
receiving some
services for which they other my wise
might be deemed too rich so a parent
could save for the child's future but
not in doing so endanger their ability
to get into that group home or sheltered
workshop or received in tight
entitlements there's another one called
the preventing harmful restraint
seclusion in Schools Act
sometimes autistic children and other
children act out in school and there's
been obviously some horrific stories
about restraints and inappropriate
seclusion I've seen some of this it's
truly horrifying and so this is meant to
set federal standards that would help to
legislate that one thing that's pending
is a global autism assistance act and if
you want to talk about a drop in the
bucket now we're talking about ten
million dollars over three years to help
the world and but it's a start
I mean this is something that wouldn't
have occurred to anyone twenty years ago
just the way you know what I'm talking
about his recent legislation wouldn't
have occurred to anyone this is to get
the world in developing countries
somewhere up to the standards and
thinking about the types of educational
opportunities that we offer here and
services and maybe at each the teachers
and information sharing program so I'm
going to close with just a little bit
about international legal perspectives
because as you can imagine we're very
very fortunate in this country to sort
of be at the vanguard of this and it's a
sliding scale all over the world I'd
have to say that disabilities in general
and certainly autism because it's not a
visible disability is treated quite
differently even if there are laws on
the books in certain countries
protecting the rights of individuals
with disabilities autism is one of I'd
say that the last ones to be seen it's
often seen as bad behavior or a curse
upon a family or in you know in since
it's incurable why bother
certainly the EU many of the countries
in the EU have very in Europe have very
sophisticated programs and plays many
based on
or in collaboration with American
programs I just picked two countries
that happen to be the two most populous
in the world and where I've spent a lot
of time with my child and it's been
interesting to see in India the national
government has sponsored health
insurance for people with autism you
know we just did that they did that a
long time ago actually they have had tax
deductions available for families with
children with autism the reality of
course is that the people many of the
people of India lives so far below the
poverty line that these are really
things that in order to a very small
percentage of the population they did
ratify the UN Convention on the Rights
of persons with disabilities everything
is done by Boards in India the Central
Board of Secondary Education allows up
to three hours of extra time on exams
for students with autism so these are on
things like you know our version of
maybe the SATs or something like that we
might not recognize that as exactly the
the accommodation that we would want for
such a thing but this is a step the evil
and reality the available of autism
education and therapy is very very
limited I've been to schools for
children with autism in India they're
usually the children of the elite of the
embassy community in rural India it's
it's unheard of the children are
typically raised home and uneducated and
then in China and China has actually
done an interesting kind of long-term
study they have nine-year compulsory
education for all children and they
encourage rather than mandate that
schools include children with
disabilities so the encouragement isn't
necessary in the world it might happen
although teachers are rewarded based on
how well people do on tests and how what
kind of progress they make through their
schools and if children with
disabilities and autism are not really
going to progress at the same rate they
may not they may fall through the cracks
there's an estimate of about two million
individuals with autism and at least
eighty percent of them not being
diagnosed and
chyna I would suspect the number is
actually much higher and there's not
currently a real efficient way of trying
to evaluate or tighten that number it
was recently regarded as a real illness
on until then it had been thought of as
either a behavioral problem or
comparables cerebal palsey mental
illness and not segregated out on its
own or given special thought there is no
special curriculum for autism in most
places again the schools for children
with autism in China tend to be largely
populated by the ruling elite and by
foreigners doing business in that
country embassies etc so that's about
the really fast and dirty version of the
law regarding special education autism
and related disorders left out a lot
more than I've said obviously but I'm
certainly happy to answer any questions
or you know whatever you would like to
ask yes
yes that's
oh yes
very well yes sure and let me repeat the
question is just what about schools
where they admit draw a distinction
between medically diagnosed autism and
educationally diagnosed are not
recognized autism it's interesting my
theory has always been and the one that
I think has been most successful when I
would urge parents who are able or
guardians who are able to do so is to
certainly never walk into that first
meeting with the team the IEP team
without medical documentation sometimes
schools will order you and will do
exactly the right thing and get an
independent medical evaluation but this
distinction between a doctor saying the
child has autism and the school saying
well you made eye contact and noses
numbers in my opinion and thankfully in
the opinion of the law most times is the
doctor wins it is a medical diagnosis
that is not a classroom diagnosis
certainly classroom observation is
important but in order to establish the
legal foundation for eligibility for
services
if a reputable physician therapist
psychologist etc someone who's qualified
to make such a diagnosis is done so the
school may in fact be worried that
someone has gone out and gotten a hired
gun and is soliciting some type of
diagnosis for whatever purposes and may
want to have another evaluation done
even in those cases I have seen the
school still say well but he counts
perfectly well he can talk no if the
child has autism I think that the
handshakes when you get to that box on
the IEP form but that box should be
checked because that is the one that
opens the door to services for the child
so
I know that that is a practice that
occurs sometimes it's regrettable that
is one where I think parents would do
well is one instance where maybe the
Internet is a good place for getting
informations great place for charlatans
but also a good place to walk in with a
couple of pages printed out from the IDE
a-and there's some wonderful websites
that are truthful and realistic and can
just say you know no when you have a
medical diagnosis and you meet the
following criteria the school must
capitulate so that's why we're frankly
if it went on long enough that would be
worthy of due process Yeah right
yes I in the question is that what about
the flip side and absolutely as an
advocate that's even more maddening to
me is because if I'm involved it's
usually because the parent has asked me
to be it's always because the parent has
asked me to be involved in the case I
only do pro bono work on behalf of
parents and children and so I'm there as
their advocate but as soon as somebody
says something like well we want to
provide applied behavior analysis well
my neighbor told me that that's how they
trained the seals SeaWorld and I don't I
think that sounds cruel and unusual I
don't want that and sometimes you see
the frustration in the face of educators
who actually do want to reach out for a
child and try to help them and it
that's even more maddening in a way
because I typically you can go to a due
process and win in the other instance
where you have reputable doctor saying
you know but a parent is entitled to
what they want they may in fact take
their child out in homeschool that child
do a lot of other things to be evasive
they don't want the label and you know
part of what being a good advocate is I
think don't fear the label it's it can
be your friend and can work
affirmatively with you no one really
reads these IEP s outside of a very
small group so the neighbors don't have
to know if you don't want them to know
they may guess you know because of
behavior and other things but but yes
it's true that sometimes schools will
reach out and sometimes it's cultural
sometimes it's just an educational thing
or mistrust of the system mind control
whatever it is but yes in some instances
parents refuse very legitimate and
well-intentioned services very
frustrating I don't know how to deal
with that one frankly very well
right
right
right
question is what about home based
services or or even services outside of
the school setting and yes the law does
say that we want children to be able to
generalize these skills so it may be
that you know very often in a child with
autism is rewarded for being the quiet
one who sits in the corner that's not
good therapy for that child probably but
they're seen as the model student
this is our best autistic student in the
school because he or she doesn't say
anything and fills out the papers like
they're supposed to
a child may turn into a maniac at home
and may have without the structure of
the school may completely lose it and
and need significant intervention and
often may be doing self injurious
behavior or engaging in wandering you
know lots of things it is certainly
possible schools schools should address
generalization outside of the classroom
a good IEP we'll look forward to that
member if it's not in the IEP you're
unlikely to get it so you have to walk
in the door anticipating that it's
always possible to reconvene an IEP to
and so meeting and so if something
evolves you can refine this later on but
that should be built into the IEP
they're not going to just spontaneously
say well let's come to the house Tuesday
night hide behind the curtains and watch
well Jimmy you know swings from the
chandeliers but but they will if it's in
the IEP and you have to get them to
agree to that that sometimes takes you
know anywhere from just subtle
suggestion sometimes I suggest for
example that parents videotaped this
kind of conduct because the school will
be dumbfounded they're fine they're
terrific in school nicest little kid we
have and then you show a videotape of a
Tasmanian devil outside the classroom
and they really legitimately can't
believe that's the same child so I find
that by giving the school as much
evidence again in some areas that might
be seen this ability antagonistic and I
think it's important to maintain as good
a relationship and as close to a
collaborative relationship with the
school system as it's possible so if
it's presented as I know this is hard to
believe based on the reports that are
coming home about my child but take a
look this is what every night is and
there's a abuse of our pet and there's
you know bite marks everywhere and
here's some hospitalization reports for
you know everyone's been eaten alive at
home that may help in fact to get
services particularly as you accumulate
that and if that service if that's
conduct that should begin for example
after an IEP is in place it's certainly
very very possible in a right to say you
know we have something new we have to
deal with this it's out of school we're
having another ie another meeting we're
going to draft revisions to the IEP to
address this conduct
right and there's still school districts
that will say that it the question is
whether or not yeah what are you doing
that the school district says no some
school districts still say they don't
reduce extended school years
they don't do transportation they don't
do you name it swimming lessons like you
know whatever it is that you might feel
and it's the job of the Advocate to try
to educate the school system in the
nicest possible way
at first about there are rights and
obligations and I think that getting
documentation is is the way to really do
it there's almost nothing that hasn't
been denied is something that if it's
something that someone has received
somewhere else it hasn't it's also been
denied in a million other places so I
really think that that's part of the
ongoing and very fatiguing advocacy that
takes place on the part of whoever is in
charge of that child's care or most
invested in it whether it's a you know
an advocate a lawyer parent guardian
whatever
yes and adulthood is the scary beyond
and and you know it's interesting I just
was in Los Angeles and I received a lot
of materials from the Los Angeles Police
Department which has a very robust
program for educating police officers
about individuals with autism and my
friend is a police commissioner in LA
and that has been his particular area of
interest and so just now police
departments and other places are
beginning to be trained because you are
going to see what happens the school
door closes and are we driving or you
know what what are we doing we're
allowed to drink we're you know all
sorts of things happen and so I do think
that as our population ages in them you
know we have this ever-growing mass
that's coming forward we are going to
see increased emphasis on earlier
interventions in what will later become
adult bad behaviors one thing I suggest
to parents who have a child on the
spectrum who may be inclined to be a bit
of a wild child
and they speak from personal experiences
to go to the local police station and
firehouse and EMTs once a year with a
picture and say here here's my child if
seen alone if picked up for shoplifting
big hobby or doing anything else like
that you know this is a child with
autism they're stickers you can get for
your house let's say occupant with
autism if you can't just fire may not
respond to verbal commands and look in
the closets go to the base you know so I
think there's clues that we can give the
outside world to that helps them to
bring it in so you don't want you know
you don't want to put your person in a
t-shirt that says I have autism and put
this you know label for the world to see
but there has to be some recognition
that people individuals with autism are
going to need lifetime services
I mean think about the geriatric
implications you know there's very few
documented geriatric cases and there's
not much case law about it but it is
coming and it's going to be big and I
don't know that we're necessarily
prepared for that so that's law that
will be coming up okay